hey youtubers is Charlie so agents of
shield is back tonight so I thought I'd
do a refresher video on the Inhumans the
back half of agents of shield season 2
is going to be all about explaining who
their culture their society are the
Inhumans that you see in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and the TV shows and
the movies are going to be a little bit
different from what they are in the
comics so I'll try to explain what the
difference is but I'm going to start
with their original origin story from
the comics they suffer from the same
problem that a lot of big Marvel
characters have they belong to a group
of people whose origin is tied to
another group that Marvel no longer has
the IP for for the films and TV shows so
let's get started the characters were
created by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby so
totally expect a Stan Lee cameo in 2019
whenever the movie comes they appeared
for the first time in Fantastic Four
number 45 in that issue Stan Lee intro
most of who would become the royal
family but at the time the Inhumans were
just these few characters there was
Black Bolt crystal Medusa Gorgon Karnak
lockjaw and Triton the plot of some of
those early Stan Lee's stories was kind
of whimsical but it was the swinging 60s
which I know sounds kind of like a
spider-man joke but you get the idea you
know the characters were really
interesting but sometimes some of the
story beats were a little bit funny so
the first time we see them Johnny Storm
is getting stood up for a date and as
he's grumbling his way walking back to
the Baxter building he sees a mysterious
redhead in an alleyway who turns out to
be crystal mystified he tries to follow
her shows her his powers in an alleyway
which isn't a euphemism for pulling his
pants down if he did that today he would
totally get arrested let's go to this
dark alleyway and I'll show you
something really special crystal reveals
that she also has special powers
introduces her special dog Locke job he
opens a portal and crystal takes Johnny
Storm to her home nowadays this would be
a story that parents would show their
kids to tell them why you don't go home
with strangers so Johnny Storm gets to
Seattle and for the first time
that's the inhuman secret city that's
cloaked from view across their history
in the comics it's moved around in terms
of its location relative to earth but
initially it started on the moon here's
where things get a little bit funny
Johnny Storm meets the rest of the royal
family and realizes that he's seen
Medusa as part
of the frightful four they're like an
evil version of the Fantastic Four so
remember this is issue number 45 when
we're seeing them for the first time
Medusa appeared in issue number 36 in an
evil team-up called the frightful four I
think what probably ended up happening
is as Stanley liked her character so
much that he wanted to make her an
inhuman but had to find a way to explain
how she could be in that team and also
be an inhuman so the official
explanation became that she had amnesia
quote-unquote while she was fighting
with the frightful four Stanley has a
long history of moving characters around
in terms of you know what their stories
are which teams they belong to sometimes
it creates some continuity errors
nowadays what Marvel does is they just
create like earth-shattering universe
events like the battleworld stuff that's
happening so after that first appearance
the Inhumans just kind of bounced around
a couple of different titles until they
got their own title in 1975 it only ran
for about twelve issues that trend
continued for a little while they would
just get limited runs from time to time
so they got another one in 1998 then a
different one in 2000 then again in 2003
and 2007 so as you can see they've been
kind of like this weird little group of
characters that Marvel brings out every
once in a while but historically they
were never popular enough to sustain
their own ongoing title like the bigger
Marvel characters that might change
whenever the movie comes out though
movie sales always boost Marvel's comics
sales after that first Robert Downey jr.
iron man came out sales of Iron Man
comics shot through the roof the lure of
Inhumans is really cool too but like a
lot of Stan Lee characters he introduces
the characters first and then like many
issues later he'll flesh out their
backstory originally their backstory was
tied to the kree-skrull war the Kree
were looking for a weapon to use against
the squirrel so they spent millennia
genetically tampering with humans on
earth eventually they abandoned the
project after a prophecy predicted that
an inhuman would rise and destroy the
supreme intelligence who failed to
appear in the guardians of the galaxy
movie I know we're all hoping to see
more Korean guardians of the galaxy too
but it's not confirmed
so all this Kree scroll war stuff was
going on the Inhumans over time
developed their own internal society the
biggest part of their culture was based
on genetic engineering in this rigid
caste structure it dictated what jobs
you could have who you could marry so
naturally by design the most powerful
humans were members of the royal family
and they are very xenophobic which is
why even after the Kree abandon them
they continued to keep their city hidden
blackbolt is a member of the Illuminati
and appears in the Avengers a lot but
crystal has historically been their
biggest ambassador and in terms of
crossover characters she's been a member
of Fantastic Four and she was a member
of the Avengers for a long time
Medusa to a lesser extent - there was
like a very Romeo and Juliet thing going
on with Johnny Storm and crystal for a
long time so that was like a way to
bridge their cultures in the comics for
the most part they are allies with the
heroes of Earth but they still have
their own agenda I mean it's like Namor
and Black Panther they both serve with
the Illuminati but their first priority
is always to their own people so let's
move into terrigenesis that is the
foundation for their society and the
process by which they activate their
powers so taking in the mists and
getting powers isn't what makes someone
an inhuman that's something that's
passed down through genetics so there
are Inhumans walking around that have
not taken in the mist that they don't
have special powers but in order to take
advantage of the mist you do have to
have those inhuman genetic markers the
TV show kind of explored this where like
Skye trip and Raina all took in the mist
but Tripp did not have inhuman DNA so it
killed him and gave powers to Skye and
Raina the TV shows really simplified
that the process by which terrigenesis
happens you know and how they find these
other inhuman people they've kind of
tied it to the Kree but I don't know how
much they're gonna explain that because
the Kree are largely a group they show
up in the guardians of the galaxy movies
so they might keep them there most of
what we see on the TV show is just going
to focus on the Inhumans living on earth
in secret groups so I'm not expecting to
see at LAN or any of the royal family
what I'm hoping is is that they weave
the idea of the Inhumans living on earth
into age of Ultron Civil War and the
rest of the movies obviously building up
to the actual Inhumans movie nothing's
been confirmed but I know there a lot of
questions about Scarlet Witch and
quicksilver's powers as far as we know
right now their powers flow from the
mind gem so they're slightly different
from the Inhumans so I'm not going to
call them Inhumans they have confirmed a
few inhuman characters that they've cast
for agents of shield already they're
minor characters there are some people
that appear in the comics but I'm just
going to wait for them to appear in
episodes before I talk about them so
like tonight if we meet
new characters I'll just explain that in
my episode video there's all kinds of
cool stuff that we can talk about like
the relationships within the royal
family like Black Bolt evil brother
Maximus the mad he has a son with Medusa
named Ahura just in general Marvel gonna
save all the best stuff for the movies
that's not coming out till july 2019 I
know I know that's a long ways off the
interesting thing is that that movie is
coming out after infinity War part 2
which i think is kind of weird so in
humans is right now the last movie in
phase 3 so here's my big question for
you guys which Inhumans from the comics
do you want to see on the TV show I know
we're all hoping for the Kamala Khan
miss Marvel but I don't think that's
going to happen right now they're really
pushing Skye and Raina as the two main
characters they're like two sides of the
same coin Raina who spent her entire
life trying to become her true self
learn about her heritage and Skye who
wants absolutely nothing to do with it
so now like you have two characters that
are going to be exploring their new
powers in their relationship to their
people that's like the main story for
the second half of the season exploring
the culture of the Inhumans and watching
them develop their powers the
interesting thing about Raina is is that
she got what she wanted but because her
transformation physically altered her so
much she's going to wind up in this
mystique type situation like mystique
from x-men people will probably look
down on her appearance as a deformity so
for her it's like an evil Genie
situation your wish was granted but what
you got isn't exactly what you asked for
so don't forget new episodes starts
tonight be sure to subscribe to get it
I'll post it after the episode airs and
there is a new Avengers trailer coming
on Thursday so I'll do new breakdown
video for that I'll probably do another
bonus Avengers video too while you guys
wait for all that to drop you can click
here to catch up with all my agents of
shield videos from the the mid-season
finale last year and you can click here
to learn about a maybe spider-man
post-credits scene in Avengers there's
just Danny Elfman just composing some
music for it so we might see like a
teaser but I don't think they've cast
the actor yet thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight now
let's all do the thing
you